чим більший реєстр чим більше в ньому
даних тим складніший він і в збереженні
і в опрацюванні це не треба робити Нащо
це все переобтяжувати речами Хто яку
музику слухає Хто яку не знаю художника
любить або книжки читає Ну ідіотизм далі
286 про електронний кабінет який має
бути значить зареєстровани військово
зобов'язання абсолютно незрозуміло як це
прив'язано яки чином це буде
співпрацювати з іншими частинами реєстру
Ну просто декларативна якась норма друзі
давайте замість цього Приймемо закон про
демобілізацію військових визначимо
термін служби 18 місяців я пропоную уряд
говорить 36 давайте дискутувати приймати
короткий зрозумілий закон прийняти закон
про звільнення вже строковиків нарешті а
не вигадувати декларативні норми і
робити якісь незрозумілі реєстри